so you've gotten
a lot of people who are innocent
uh you def i get i guess
revealed their innocence demonstrated
their innocence
what's that process like what's it like
emotionally psychologically what's it
like
legally to fight the system
in uh through the process of revealing
sort of uh
the innocence of a human being yeah
emotionally and psychologically it can
be
taxing i follow a model
of uh what's called empathic
representation and that is i get to know
my clients and their family i get to
know their strivings their aspirations
their fears their sorrows
so that certainly uh
sometimes can do psychic injury on one
if you you know you get really invested
and really sad and
or happy and it uh it it it
does become emotionally uh taxing but
the idea
of uh someone sitting in jail for 20
years
completely innocent of a crime can you
imagine sitting there every day for 20
years knowing
that you factually did not do the thing
that you were convicted of by a jury of
your peers
it it's got to be the most incredible
thing in the world
um what the but the people who do it and
the people who make it and come out on
the other side
as productive citizens are folks who say
and they they they've come to an inner
peace in their own
minds and they say these bars aren't
going to define
me that my my humanity
is is there and it's immutable
and they are not bitter which is amazing
i
i i would tend to think that i'm not
that good of a person i would be
bitter for every day of 20 years if i
were in in jail
for something but you know but but
people tell me that you know that they
can't survive like that one cannot
survive like that
and you have to come to terms with it
and uh
and uh the the people whom i've
exonerated i mean they they come out
uh most of them uh come out and
and they just uh really just take on
life with a vim
and vigor without uh bitterness and it's
it's a beautiful thing to see
you